ça me donne une idée j'ai envie
franchement francis est ce que vous
pouvez nous montrer avec ingrid comment
on fait un baiser de cinéma et jeux je
vais former des couples ici et vous
allez essayer de faire comme consigne
basse que dans 26 ans bras déjà il ya un
couple que je veux enlever tout de suite
série cabanon
je vais faire je vais faire les cas
bertron je vais faire gilles verdez et
angela lorente je vais faire ici je vais
faire maintenant mon rigolez pas aux
attaques isabelle moret et enfin valérie
bénaïm avec thierry m'ont placé le
couple tranquille un ver sur le dimanche
le samedi soir devant le fil à 30 il une
fois par mois on fait patins ont fait
part à gaza lors du ces le couple
tranquille d'accord alors france est-ce
que vous pouvez nous montrer parce que
c'est vrai que vous allez vous embrasser
tous les soirs mais c'est vrai alors
montrez nous montrez nous comment il
faut faire il va ils vont essayer de
faire la même chose qu'on voit à 100
tous qu'il est très très très habile en
la matière non c'est vrai francis 76 ans
francis oui
non
et vous savez quoi je me suis échauffé
je me sers à coca
attention attention moi que le début
baroin comme cela vous bah oui on fait
comme ça le tour de délégués de
s'embrasser pour de vrai ici on
s'embrasse mode vrai il n'ya que du vrai
du vrai dur est du vrai vous allez voir
moi et mokhtar et je peux vous dire que
j'ai pas choisi le leb le plus simple à
pratiquer la langue rugueuse en plus
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit allez-y
alors puisque ça vous serez n'est pas ce
que ça vous fait déjà mon avis ça va
nous faire rire vous êtes chaud tant que
j'ai choisi mathieu
tiens on sait pas ce que c'est une
épreuve pour lui c'est pas sympa non
mais non eh ouais non mais son frère rob
vos idées vos mains un temps donné comme
on fait quand on a signé ça devient
gênant ça va quand même nom malaisie bas
les oranje m'en bats les idées dont deux
secondes c'est pas vous qui m c'est
parce que je me rabats alors non mairie
gaudry pas non mais vous cacher quoi
on travaille par benali mémo allez allez
allez y est égal au chela mais non mais
un
c'est kaka mais tout le monde a
quelqu'un paye pas fana pas quelqu'un
c'est ce qu'elle est en train de faire
pendant que je suis tranquillement en
direct dans cette émission
ah oui
non mais oh la la
mais
non mais attendez attendez attendez même
même leur bisous et ringard
besson et roger qui viennent le hohneck
arrêté environ brand vont enlever mois
s'agir ou non mais on dirait que tu
viennes de blabla et d'obus n'arrêtent
pour nos amours salut tu vois je t'avais
dit que c'était dans la salle de bain
non mais attendez non mais quelle
horreur et vous dégoûter public était
gentil je suis sa grille d'été
dégueulasse ce baiser au il était
pudique
merci graisseuse dit la vérité j'en ai
assez je sais pas je vais tester
s alala est ça j'achète et ça jamais
alors on verra
mon dieu voilà dans la tanière tonéo à
chauffer le lait fait pas de mal
faites attention parce que iannone qui
peut cogner
j'attends ce qu'on ferme les yeux chérie
ça concerne attendait juste avant angela
c'est notre cible j le nom je voulais
une proposition vous avez le droit au
switch vous pouvez échanger contre
chamerois tout de suite c'est comme ça
c'est quoi
vous avez raison vous avez pas se
décider voilà de de démarrer par le pire
bon allez allez on y va fermer les yeux
rouges ne s'est pas attaqué cubain
et lounge et la lorraine c'est pas la
dernière regardait
franchement ça alors alors à ce mr aulas
et la basse bien quoi il en va bien mais
à très très vite la marque essentielle
et right to play ben oui les i oi
les enfants et enfin le couple qu'on
l'attendait tous
mais s'est refusé à les dire et avec lui
des découpages mais pas du tout assez
sexy j'embrasse moctar bah non il
expliqué
ça non mais tu louis on exploite et gère
rien du tout et on va vous expliquerai
que mon mari un bail et quand il
s'appelle bachar comment l'achat rachat
acharné bachar assad a lancé la commande
tête font pas ça qui nous regardent
ottawa sports c'est rien les meufs y en
a plein c'est john si l'on rigole sais
rien non si ça vous gêne vous dire votre
votre gêne oui non
alors on est venus s'amuser à aller bien
là mais les talons les talons marocain
comme on l'appelle tunisie hamma pardon
excusez moi
arrêtez cette poussée à désosser
sexually ling a rien de sexuel là dedans
à